I just want y'all to take a good look
that is how you steal a red carpet but
here's the question did Jennifer Lopez
steal that look I'm asking you I would
never say that okay never cuz she's the
style Queen but we are getting some
serious deja vu with another a listener
mm-hmm but I'm here's the thing if you
had any doubt that she is still Jenny
from the block wait until you see the
moment that she stepped in to protect
her mama don't mess with her mama that's
right don't mess with mr. dubaye but
before we get to that let's get into
that Diwali
nobody dominates the red carpet right
like JLo I love the color number the
drama of it a gown fit for a diva
because it was dramatic and
high-maintenance even her man a-rod had
to step aside and check out the way that
dress filled the entire van on the way
to the second act New York premiere once
parked it required two handlers for its
red carpet takeover and if the gown
looks a little familiar well it's the
same one Julia Roberts rocked with
sneakers on the cover of Harper's Bazaar
and can you believe JLo has warned 11
different looks in just two days
oh yeah we work together my stylist and
we have a lot of fun but fun wouldn't be
the word used earlier in the day when
Jenny from the block came out in full
force while out with her mom Lupe as the
two navigated their way through the
massive crowd an autograph seekers
appears to have elbow glue paste face
JLo was not happy as she guided her mom
safely inside wow this is my office
despite the drama
JLo says she's thrilled to have her
press tour in a hometown it's always
great to do it in New York because then
I know my family's gonna be there listen
take it all away when somebody messes
with miss McQuaid and by the way it was
her birthday yesterday Jennifer's mother
alone